are we at a stage that you should have a
business plan in place before you
approach crowdfunding uh yeah I think
you need a business I mean you need a
business plan for anything you know you
need a business plan for your life you
need a businessman forever especially if
you're doing a documentary where you're
following somebody around and it you
could go on forever you know you want to
have a plan for everything and obviously
financially you need to have a plan for
everything the crowdfunding can
absolutely be used as part of your
business plan I think it's a good idea I
know personally for me in the eye I know
this is also for other filmmakers we
don't really do a Kickstarter until
we've shot enough of the movie where we
know it's going to be a movie which is I
made that mistake of my first
Kickstarter that we raised funds before
we even shot the movie luckily the movie
is gonna be a movie but but i think
that's that's a risk you shouldn't take
with people's money personally um so in
that Kickstarter says there's no reason
why you can't you know do a campaign for
your movie two or three times and all
through the course of especially if you
do a dog or a little indie film you're
going to shoot the movie and then six
months from now you're going to have the
rough cut so you can space it out and
that's a much better way I think too
because then you can lower your your
pride in your what you're asking for
donation wise I mean that's what you
know the documentary were little you
know we you should always like shoot the
movie for as little as you can shoot it
for but you hope for okay well maybe we
can make up the money we spend our
pocket on a Kickstarter or through
grants or through whatever me or
sponsorships and it's very rolling with
a dog the docs you know it's it's never
a process that ends like you never go
okay well yeah well we're getting a
funding and four months and then we'll
shoot the movie it's always like okay oh
we can apply for this
we can do that we can do our Kickstarter
campaign because we shot the movie and
now we edited so now we can do another
campaign and a lot kind of stuff
you